we now know eight Americans are among 12
people killed in a tourist bus crash in
Mexico three Americans who died were
from the same family ana Behar her 11
year old son Daniel and 78 year old
Fania Shamas were killed in this
accident Andy and Jodi Fritz both 51
years old were also killed some of the
18 people injured are recovering and
chuta Mall Mexico Manuel Bojorquez is
there with details of the investigation
man well good morning good morning
Mexican prosecutors indicate that skid
marks at the crash site show the driver
may have been speeding a Baker family
member tells us his nephew Moises has
been flown to Miami where he's being
treated for broken ribs and blood
between his chest and lungs
he is also mourning his wife son and
mother-in-law it's a great loss doctor
Israel Franco's nephew Moises Behar was
on the bus with his wife two children
and mother-in-law he and his older son
David survived the crash
the others were killed he clearly was in
shock and the way he told me so
nonchalant that his son died in his arms
I knew that he was absolutely in shock
Franco's solve video of his nephew
walking around the crash scene looking
for his family the last thing you're
thinking about when you go on a cruise
is your safety dad something as when I
always a taking a bus to go to somewhere
it's going to end up leaving you dead or
you know your children orphaned Red
Cross responder Marcelino Pettis says
the crash is the worst he's ever seen
you saw that they were clearly in shock
see they were in a desperate state he
said crying some were screaming because
of their injuries and finding their
relatives dead cruise lines have no
regulatory oversight Jim Walker is a
former defense attorney for cruise lines
who now represents passengers in several
cases against Cruise Lines he says they
don't do proper background checks it's
pretty much being offered as by way of
word-of-mouth they're operating
primarily to make as much money as they
can there is conflicting information
about the bus driver earlier State
officials here in Quintana TRO had said
the driver was injured and being held
later the state prosecutor said the
drivers whereabouts are unknown
Nora Wow Manuel Bojorquez in Mexico
thank you